hello everyone Emily Asif Deemer was a
player of a very peculiar style he
enjoyed some very unorthodox openings
and as you'll see in this game while
this game is a masterpiece of
peculiarity as the story goes in 1931
Emily was out of work so he joined the
not the Nazi Party and well he mostly
did chess related stuff he was he was
present at all major international chess
tournaments and well after the war ended
he did try to make a living out of chess
you know he was trying to give
simultaneous exhibitions playing in
tournaments but didn't this didn't
really go his way he couldn't make a
living out of this and later in life he
kind of gave up on chess and he started
studying nostradamus the famous 16th
century French clairvoyant and well it's
said that over the over 25 years he sent
over 10,000 letters regarding this
matter and well of course he was
committed to a psychiatric clinic where
he was not allowed to play chess anymore
as they said chess was too stressful for
someone in his state but later in 1971
they kind of released him and he did
play first board for a German chess club
and well but he did stay stay in the
hospital he lived there for the rest of
his life but this game was played in the
1984 this was six years before before
Emal's death he's playing against the
Tomas healing I couldn't really find any
information on the guy neither a photo
of him but I did find it he was raided
somewhere around 20 to something hundred
so I think it's pretty fair to say that
this is a game between two masters so
let's see this game ml is a white and
mr. Thomas is black we have d4 Knight to
f6 so it starts as an Indian game and
already we have f3 this is something
called the pale face attack as mo was
pretty fond of her openings that
included moves upon to f3 we have D 6
and now e4 we have G 6 and here mo plays
G 4 so already going
very aggressive we have Bishop to g7 and
here we have g5 or kicking tonight out
of f6 so Knight to d7 and here we have F
for Black has the right idea he wants to
break a white center he plays C 5 and we
have d5 now and already this is a very
very chain a very strange at pawn
structure
this is move seven so it's it kind of
looks looks like a crab with pincers
so black plays b5 of course he wants to
get some space on the Queen side and we
have c3 kind of not allowing this Bishop
to be so powerful and g7 we have a six
by black and h4 we have nice to be six
and the mo continues with his bone
pushing ideas h5 we have e six and now
he plays h6 now kicking the bishop out
of g7 so Bishop to f8 and now he plays a
four he wants to he wants to break this
pawn chain black created on the Queen
side and black doesn't react the to this
as he is a pretty underdeveloped so
instead he plays it captures on d5 and
now Emma wishes a5 so attacking this
Knight and b6 and we have night night
night six to d7
so E captor Sun d5 and if you look at
this position well black is pretty much
completely cramped in there there's
doesn't really seem to be a piece he can
develop I mean he can develop this
Bishop to b7 and this Bishop on the e7
that's about it so he does he plays
Bishop to e7 and we have c4 by mo we had
f6 now he's trying to break this pawn
structure and get his King to safety
that way we are F 7 and rook to e8 and
we have C captures on b5 now and well
Thomas plays G kept F captures on g5 and
well again mo doesn't develop a piece he
plays f5 and this was probably a blacks
best best moment to get back into the
game as well probably a move like 95 or
even cast
castling might have been okay for
example if he castled okay he does allow
f captors and g 6h capture some g6 and
maybe b6 here I don't know the wife was
probably tried to save this pawn on the
Queen side but after King to h7 okay
blacks King is kind of feeling the draft
there but I mean white King has no
defense whatsoever so this would have I
think this would have been much better
than what black played after f5 black
played G captures on f5 and here we have
this is move 18 and white plays the
first non pawn move he plays Queen to h5
check so first move that isn't what a
pawn is it's coming with a check so King
to f8 and now Knight to f3
we have rock to g8 and now b6 now this
is well this is a very dangerous passed
pawn now Bishop to b7 and we have Knight
to c3 and as you can see white isn't
that that bad now as both Knights are in
to the game the Queen is placed nicely
on h5 so black wants to kick it out of
here he plays Knight to f6 attacking the
Queen but now this allows mo a very nice
tactic he plays Knight captures and g5
and of course this isn't the Queen
sacrifice as 936 will for the king and
the Queen so we have Knight captures on
h5 96 check King to e8 and now Knight
captures and e8 and if King captures
neither than rook captured this night on
h5 so first black plays Knight to g3
attacking this rook as well as the
bishop and we have knife capture some b7
grabbing that LightSquared Bishop there
we have Knight captures on h1 and we
have Bishop to f4 now attacking this d6
pawn we have worked the g6 defending and
we have queenside castle by mo and I to
have two attacking the rook rook to e1
and now we have King to d7 getting out
of the pin from the rook on e 1 and here
mo finds a very creative idea
he plays Knight to b5 and okay
can this not be captured was the idea
here well if I capture some b5 you get
after some b5 with check and well after
King to c8 rook captures on e7 and there
is a there is no defense against rook to
e8 checkmate
for example if black plays something
like rook to g8 then you get rook to c7
checkmate and black can defend both
threats so after night to be five he
played Knight to e4 but here and will
tricks him again
he plays rook captures on e4 and what's
the idea here can this rugby captured
well if F captors on e4 you get Bishop
to h3 check and after King to e8 you get
night to c7 check this big supper rook
and the white is winning here
so after rook captures any for the rook
cannot be captured unfortunately so
black finds
black finds a resource he plays rook to
g1 now pinning this bishop here and
we'll place rook back to e1 and here
Tomas captures rook captures on f1 real
captures on f1 and now of course this
night can be taken because there's no
more Bishop on f1 a capture some B 5 and
we have rook to g1 - pairing a nice a
nice rock lift King to c8 and now Knight
captures on the and e6 with Czech Bishop
captures Bishop captures and now Knight
to d7 and rogoff's the g8 with check
King has to go to be 7 and now pinning
the night here on g7 King has to go back
and now simply grabbing this pawn on h7
rook grabs pawn on a 5 we have b7 with
Czech now only move for the King is to
capture the pawn if he goes if you guys
came here then well this is again deadly
rook to e8 then I test the block and
this wins apiece and the game as well as
the the pawn is screaming so after b7 of
course became captured it
we have rook captures night and d7 King
to c8 and now simply h7 threatening the
Queen and we have rook to e1 check King
to see - and hear Thomas captures the
rook King captures on d7 and it doesn't
it doesn't help to play something like
rook to h1 just to try and stop the pawn
because rook to f7 well the bond is
defended and rook to f8 would check is
coming and then the pawn will be Queen
for example if any move simply check
after he was here and brings up a queen
completely winning so after Kings to c2
like decided to capture the rook
Kim captures rook on d7 we have h8 Queen
rook King captures Bishop on d6 Queen
check on the 8th King d5 and now simply
b6 and in this position Thomas Thomas
healing resigned the game so yeah a very
nice game and a very peculiar game this
was a first 17 moves were all pawn moves
by Emily Asif Deemer it's something
something not not often seen and in a
game played by a chess master so yeah
hope you hope you enjoyed this peculiar
game as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I'll see you soon